Kris Humphries has officially caught up with Kim Kardashian.
The basketball pro and the reality TV star are husband and wife.
Her publicist says the 30 - year - old Kardashian...
...and the 26 - year - old Humphries tied the knot Saturday night.
The ceremony will be televised as part of a two - part special on E! in October.
People in E! News report that Kardashian wore an ivory gown designed by Vera Wang.
Her stepfather, Bruce Jenner, walked her down the aisle in front of some 440 guests.
It's the first marriage for Humphries and the second for Kardashian.
She was married to music producer Damon Thomas from 2000 to 2004.
Nicole Grether, The Associated Press.